you drink a lot of water meditate and
ginger
i just started the first time i
meditated my mama pissed me off it was
my first time ever on my grandma like
for real for real my first time
meditating ever i'm meditating
it's like i got like one minute left she
coming down what the [ __ ] you doing
i'm proud of the guy if it's my first
time ever trying to [ __ ]
she coming at me like what the [ __ ]
how deep in were you like probably the
guy it was like a minute left
i didn't want to like keep knowing her
she like so you can't [ __ ] hit me you
know that mama's getting
it hey when you told your mom your mom
when you told your mom you were
meditating did she laugh at you uh i
i was like when i first like when she
came in and like
blew blew me and i finally changed whoa
okay
no no no no no no wait wait no no no no
chicago no i know
okay okay y'all gonna put me on to this
no no chicago slaying like
like like like me i was like okay she'll
piss you off okay okay i'll be i'm just
saying
that she watched the interview yeah
that means like like pissed me off yeah
i just thought about it the way he
thought about it like now it's stuck in
my head like that like
[ __ ] like like it's something like if
something makes you mad like damn i
should blew the hell out of me feel me
you know i'm saying the show so if like
if he made you mad you'd be like man you
blew me bro yeah hell yeah
i ain't gonna fly yeah you just blew me
see you you making it like a homo ass
wave folks so now i don't want to say
yeah but like hey i'm just saying you
might
y'all might want to leave that like that
until you just put it like that
you just blew me like you just blew like
you're bad
it's right right yeah so safe to say
that's some nut [ __ ] though no yeah it's
super super
all my life no other way you uh
[Music]
levine like misses a shot at the end of
a bulls game he'd be like man zach
levine blew me last night bro
hell yeah if i'm on fanduel [ __ ] yeah
talk to him [ __ ] yeah
dude hey buddy hey if you know you know
that's what we gonna say bro y'all know
what we talking about y'all know what we
saying so